on this Saturday night the protests over
policing the demonstrations in Canada's
capital demanding change and the push to
keep the momentum alive trumpeting Trump
in Tulsa where racial tensions run high
the battle between China and India two
nuclear powers on the brief plus
basketball is ready to hit the courts
hockey wants in the arena's but do the
players have their head in the game
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with more anti-racist
protests on Canadian streets
demonstrators in Ottawa and Toronto are
out again today demanding systemic
change to policing across this country
as Abigail Beeman reports many see the
movement making a difference and want to
keep the momentum alive in Toronto
demonstrators took a knee near the US
consulate a show of solidarity against
racism on both sides of the border I
just wanted to keep the momentum going
momentum some fear will dissipate nearly
four weeks after demonstrations began in
Toronto there were calls to defund
police a lot of us come from immigrant
communities and when you start out in an
immigrant community a lot of people live
in government-funded housing
neighborhoods like Regent Park that are
poorer and they don't have youth
outreach programs there they don't have
a lot of things that they need to
diminish crime to have to be well to
succeed in life and stuff like that and
that's why we're here Ottawa's Marge
started at police headquarters organized
by a group called justice for abdomen
the 2016 death of police violence the
officer involved was charged criminally
and that case is ongoing we would like
our police services to be about
community safety it's about well-being
and security not about enforcement not
about armed officers coming into
situations they should not be in it's
about ensuring that our community feel
safe and don't feel threatened and amid
the calls for systemic change
Ottawa's police chief listened from the
edge of the crowd this week the prime
minister once again acknowledged
systemic racism and promised action we
are going to be taking a strong bold
concrete actions to go at systemic
discrimination in this country but
offered no details at the Ottawa March
people say it's important to keep
filling the streets until change happens
and in other ways the marches have
already had an impact I work for the
Herman and I felt pretty alone during
the the George Floyd in tonight I didn't
really see a lot of my colleagues
outraged as I was but when I'm out on
the street here I really feel that you
know what I'm not alone in my outrage
and it it's nice not feel alone
Abagail Beaman global news Ottawa US
President Donald Trump is kicking off
his 2020 reelection campaign against the
backdrop of calls for racial justice
today's rally is taking place in Tulsa
Oklahoma a city with a grim history when
it comes to racism hundreds of African
Americans were massacred in the city
nearly a century ago
adding to the controversy surrounding
the campaign stump is that it's going
ahead in spite of the concerns about the
resurgence of Cova 19 Oklahoma just
surpassed 10,000 confirmed cases of
kovat 19 with the number of new cases
rising steeply over the past week six
Trump campaign staffers have also tested
positive for Cova 19 the campaign team
says they're following quarantine
protocols and won't attend the rally but
Trump supporters are showing little
concern flooding the city by the tens of
thousands Jennifer Johnson reports
it's what Trump 2020 supporters have
been waiting for a rally to reignite his
campaign after months on the sidelines
and controversies it's just really
important for us in the midst of
everything going on to come out in
really great numbers and show our
support to President Trump the president
looking to rally is based after missteps
handling the Cova 19 pandemic black
lives matter protests and blockbuster
allegations in former national security
adviser John Bolton's new book the rally
is just blocks from Tulsa's Greenwood
district once the wealthiest black
community in the nation until a white
mob burned it down in 1921 one of the
worst episodes of racial violence in US
history
historians believe as many as 300 black
people were killed and more than 10,000
black residents were left homeless this
line is very important to me it's very
sacred it was warned of necessity to
take care of one another take care of
their own needs but thrived was a
thriving economic Center despite the
racial tension still in Tulsa and a
record rise in cases of koban 19 the
rally was not relocated president Trump
warning any protesters anarchists
agitators looter
lowlifes who are going to Oklahoma will
be dealt with Tulsa officials appealed
to the state Supreme Court to force
precautions like wearing masks but lost
campaign officials say masks will be
voluntary what we've got is personal
freedom letting people make those
decisions we're encouraging everyone who
would be in a high risk category to have
a negative outcome with kovat - maybe
not participate thousands are excited to
attend despite fears downpours and sunny
days many have camped out near the arena
for close to a week no worries about
Kovan attendees are having their
temperatures checked offer masks and
hand sanitizer I would pick a chance
that I get that virus but I'm not gonna
get that virus at least two members of
the White House coronavirus task force
advised the Trump campaign against
holding the rally the president is
looking for a boost and his supporters
are ready to give him one Jennifer
Johnson Global News Washington
protestors fighting racism filled
streets and parks in European cities for
a fourth weekend in London the leaders
of black lives matter are demanding to
meet with British Prime Minister Boris
Johnson they want Johnson to get rid of
the head of a new Commission on racial
inequality saying the appointee does not
believe institutional racism exists in
the UK demonstrators in Paris marched
against racism and called for an end to
police violence against the black
community this protest was permitted to
go ahead despite concerns about Cova 19
but three others were banned including
one set to take place outside the US
Embassy more fallout tonight from NGP
leader jug meat singh's comments in
Parliament this week on Wednesday Singh
was kicked out of the House of Commons
for calling the bloc québécois House
leader a racist for refusing to support
his motion dealing with systemic racism
in the RCMP the bloc's leader is
demanding an apology from Singh and now
former BQ leader she'll do Sepp is
weighing in on the matter
Mercedes Stevenson joins us to talk
about that Mercedes Robin the former
Bloc Quebecois leader had some strong
words for a jug meet Singh saying he
didn't know if Singh's reaction to the
blockhouse leader was genuine
and calling sings responds just plain
stupid no shame in his speech saying
that he recognized the existence of
systemic racism I think that sing oh the
other thing he wanted to do was to get
more support in the rest of Canada
knowing God is losing to the Liberals
even in DC so I think it was cheap
politics from Jackman singing it's more
tell them in Quebec
not at all the speaker the house is
currently deciding whether or not seeing
will have to apologize for calling the
blockhouse leader a racist so far Singh
has refused to do so and the Prime
Minister has said it's not his place to
judge Singh's actions as the only
racialized party leader in the House of
Commons she'll do Sepp thinks that
Trudeau aligning himself with Singh is a
misstep we'll also talk to mr. du SAP
about the French conservative leadership
debate which happened last week and who
he thinks can take Quebec for the party
all four candidates were fairly stilted
in their French while some fared better
than others but many political analysts
say without a strong NDP the
Conservatives will need to win seats in
Quebec in order to win the next general
election here is mr. doose Epps take on
the debate and the Conservatives chances
in Quebec given their French we chose to
listen to the comedy that was the debate
in French I mean 50 years after the
adoption of the official languages Act
in Canada those people just can't speak
French I mean I just don't understand
that and I think both of them they'd be
a O'Toole or McCain both of them are
speaking French which is worse than
Andrew Shearer Robin we'll also be
talking to Canada's former ambassador to
Beijing about China charging Michael
SPAWAR
and Michael Kovarik plus we'll have the
parliamentary budget watchdog he's
predicting a 256 billion dollar deficit
now and he doesn't understand why the
federal government is only putting out a
snapshot coming up in July and hasn't
released any kind of fiscal update when
his office has done so regularly and
finally we'll have a prominent scientist
on the show who says that assuming there
will be
kovat vaccine that within the next year
is giving people false hope and that
it's time to rethink how we'll get
through this pandemic alright thanks for
that Mercedes and you can watch all of
those interviews on the West block with
Mercedes Stevenson tomorrow right here
on Global a new twist tonight in the
conservative leadership race err no
tools team is accusing a rival of
stealing campaign data O'Toole's camp
says it has filed a formal complaint
calling for a police investigation into
the alleged actions by a member of Peter
Mackay's team they're accusing his
campaign organizer Jamie Lau of being
involved in the alleged hacking and
theft of confidential strategy data
McKay's team is dismissing the
allegations calling them mildly amusing
and Lau has responded in a tweet saying
not a single word of this is true
O'Toole and Mackay are considered to be
leading the race to replace Andrew
Shearer as the Conservative Party's next
leader the Trump administration's
efforts to block the release of John
Bolton's tell-all book have failed today
a federal judge ruled the former
National Security Adviser can move
forward in publishing his memoir the
White House was trying to stop the book
from being made public because of
concerns it contains classified
information during his ruling the judge
did make it clear he felt Bolton had
gambled with the national security of
the United States by publishing without
formal clearance from the Trump
administration the book is scheduled to
hit store shelves on Tuesday the remains
of all six Canadian soldiers killed in a
helicopter crash have now been recovered
four of the members killed were
positively identified by Ontario's Chief
Coroner they include sub-lieutenant
matthew pike from nova scotia master
corporal Matthew cousins from Ontario
captain Maxine muhawwil clan from Quebec
and captain Kevin Hagan from BC the
remains of sub-lieutenant Abigail Cobra
and captain Brendan McDonald were
identified just after the accident the
military says the bodies will be
released to the families over the coming
days the members were killed when a
cyclone helicopter crashed during a
training exercise off the coast of
Greece in April another major fight in
u.s. politics has come to an
and this one between a top federal
prosecutor and the Attorney General
Jeffrey Berman showed up at his office
today defying Attorney General William
Barr who just hours earlier else did the
lawyer last night Barr released a
statement announcing president Trump was
nominating current Securities and
Exchange Commission Chairman Jay Clayton
to succeed Berman Berman was quick to
fire back saying he has no intention of
resigning today Barr said Trump had
fired Berman but late this afternoon
Trump said he's not involved in the end
Berman gave up and stepped down
Berman's office prosecuted former Trump
confidant Michael Cohen and has been
overseeing investigations of other Trump
allies including his personal lawyer
Rudy Giuliani crews in Quebec are
scrambling to contain an aggressive
forest fire the blaze is burning north
of Quebec City in the provinces zegenei
Lac saint-jean region it scorched more
than 11,000 hectares of forest overnight
the fire threatens an area that includes
chalets and fishing camps so authorities
have evacuated a large perimeter the
fire has now burned more than 58,000
hectares of land and firefighters are
battling that blaze as a heat wave grips
parts of southern Quebec in Montreal the
humidex is forecast to hit 40 degrees
the city has created a map online
showing where people can cool off safely
some outdoor pools have reopened with
new kovat 19 restrictions the heat wave
is expected to last until Tuesday
Toronto is feeling the heat - a heat
warning has been issued with
temperatures climbing to 30 degrees the
city has opened 15 emergency cooling
centers and staff will be on hand to
remind people to maintain social
distancing in the time of Cova 19 coming
up the long fights between China and
India
tensions are running high between China
and India this week soldiers from the
two countries brought along the border
leaving at least 20 dead the dispute is
over a contested area in the Himalayas
the two neighboring nuclear powers have
fought over the border before but this
was the first time in close to six
decades that anyone has been killed as
Mike Armstrong reports both countries
are calling for de-escalation but
they're not backing down this was a
message video of Chinese military drills
in Tibet released this week the goal of
the operation according to reports to
test their soldiers capabilities
fighting at a high elevation the goal of
releasing the video is to tell its
neighbor India it's ready to fight at a
high elevation the two countries came to
blows this week in one of the most
inhospitable unforgiving and highest
regions in the world now there is no
clear demarcation between the Indian
controlled and Chinese controlled
territories the border is usually called
simply the line of actual control even
some of the lower plateaus are in an
altitude of 5000 metres a height that
affects everything from the human body
to weapons and vehicles now hundreds of
soldiers from the two companies have
been stationed basically facing off
across that line for months there's been
fear of a flare-up and Monday it
happened as you can see some soldiers
being injured according to reports it
would have been similar to this brawl in
2017 no shots were fired soldiers fought
instead with fists rocks and bats
according to India 20 of its soldiers
were killed there have been funerals
throughout the week Indian officials say
there were casualties on both sides but
China has not confirmed that instead
saying only its soldiers were on-site
for negotiations and were attacked
fatality in this foreign ministry
spokesperson says Indian troops crossed
the line provoking Chinese soldiers and
triggering the brawl there are calls on
India to retaliate for the loss of life
protesters burned the Chinese president
in effigy there also calls for
boycotting Chinese products for the
Indian prime minister who was re-elected
last year in a campaign focused on
national security the pressure is
building
para shanty da India wants peace the
Prime Minister says but if provoked will
provide an appropriate response hard
Holliman the two countries in 1962
fought a month-long war over the
disputed border hundreds of soldiers on
both sides were killed tensions have
simmered for decades the two countries
were scheduled to hold trilateral talks
this coming Tuesday with Russia despite
the dispute Indian officials say they
will participate Mike Armstrong Global
News still ahead the apology and the
investigation into a massive coronavirus
outbreak in Germany
you
you are watching global national
[Music]
brazil's government says the country has
surpassed more than 1 million confirmed
coronavirus cases that is second only to
the u.s. health specialists believe the
actual number of cases could be seven
times higher Brazilian President cha
here balsan aru is still downplaying the
risks of the virus despite nearly 50,000
deaths in three months he says the
impact of social isolation on Brazil's
economy can be even more deadly the
owner of one of Germany's largest meat
processing firms has apologized for a
mass infection at one of its plants the
plant isn't gutr slow it has now been
shut down more than 1,000 workers have
tested positive for Cova 19 and a
quarantine has been ordered for the
other 5,500 staff most are from Romania
and Bulgaria who lived in cramped
company-provided accommodation Germany's
Agriculture Minister has launched an
official investigation Via Rail is
implementing a facemask policy on its
trains the company will require
passengers to wear masks for the
duration of their trips starting next
week employees who interact with
customers are also required to wear face
coverings up next the competing factor
is complicating the return of major
league sports
Vermont sports fans have been hoping
things would get back to normal but it
looks like they may have to wait a bit
longer the MLS NFL NHL NBA and MLB have
all recently had athletes test positive
for Cova 19 Canadian teams are being
impacted the Toronto Blue Jays have now
shut down a Florida training facility
after a player exhibited symptoms and
maple leafs star player austin matthews
is isolating at his arizona home after
contracting the virus as mike drily
explains the new cases are casting doubt
on when it might be game on with
cavernous stadiums at devoid of fans the
Premier League in England certainly
doesn't look the same but Sports is
coming back and this is what it looks
like for now at least the reality is
that nothing will look the same this
year the NBA will test players for kovat
every other day
when its season restarts next month at
Disney World in Orlando or at least that
was the plan before political and
societal unrest overshadowed everything
a lot of the players just don't feel
it's an appropriate time to be playing
and with this debate that they feel like
their minds are on something somewhere
else and something else that's somewhere
else is that the many rallies being held
across the u.s. and some players have
made it clear their hearts and minds are
focused on the streets they grew up on
and not the basketball courts where they
make a living so if the NBA does resume
players could decide to stay home the
NHL could be facing a similar opt-out
dilemma for kovat not political reasons
still the NHL is now the most likely
league to resume play even as the Tampa
Bay Lightning deal with a kovat outbreak
the league plans on splitting the teams
between two as yet to be announced hub
cities Las Vegas is widely believed to
be one in one of three Canadian cities
Vancouver Edmonton or Toronto could be
chosen as well provided the 14 day
quarantine issue is addressed we are
comfortable with moving forward on an
NHL hub in one of three Canadian cities
that are asking for it Canada is open to
it as long as it is OK by the local
health authorities
the most perplexing of sports remains
baseball well the Japanese and Korean
leads have resumed play Major League
Baseball's owners and players are
squabbling with what a season would look
like and of course money provided a deal
is ratified the quarantine rule could
force the Blue Jays out of Toronto and
into their Florida facility that's going
to be interesting this is where the
Canadian factor does come into play it
doesn't happen all that often anymore
but this is one where it really does
complicating matters even more Florida
is in the midst of another kovat
outbreak and three professional teams
including the Blue Jays have shut down
their facilities because of positive
tests so while sports fans are eager to
see their teams on the court ice or
field kovat and politics could have
other ideas Mike they're like what we'll
use Toronto and that is global national
for this Saturday I'm Robin Gill tonight
your Canada is bent Saskatchewan just
west of Saskatoon we'd love to see your
corner of this country so email your
pictures to viewers at global national
calm thank you for watching and I'll see
you back here tomorrow and Monday good
night
[Music]